hey everybody today we've got an
exciting testimony to tell you
mikey jenny is going to tell us exactly
how god won his heart and man this is a
great testimony
uh you know you've won you've seen
people go
really far out into the world right but
can god truly change anyone's life
find out on this episode of led live
light exposing darkness
[Music]
we have an exciting testimony to share
with you mikey jenny has worked with
little light studios for
a number of years now i can't believe it
goes by fast it's already been a couple
of years but
you know we wanted to share with you
guys his testimony of how he came to the
lord and let me tell you
there's nobody too far gone i mean when
you
when we when you tell your story and you
see some of the pictures of where mikey
was this is kind of one of those
characters that you would actually look
at and be like
i'm not even going to waste my time
right but here mikey is
in our ministry and in our midst and man
sharing biblical truth with the world i
love it
praise god yep so how did you come
to the lord did you did you have an
upbringing in
christianity and a departing from it
yeah my parents were actually raised in
a baptist
environment so their parents were
baptists they grew up in baptist
churches they went
through those christian school and
everything so they kind of just always
believed in god you know
but uh so i was raised in church i was
raised in the
baptiste world and then we kind of
started venturing into
more charismatic word of faith kind of
exciting we saw the excitement they were
like man there's something going on in
there there's
people shouting and dancing and speaking
in tongues and healings and stuff so
we started going into those types of
churches you mean your whole family
started attending that some of them my
immediate family and my dad's sister and
his
uh you know that side over there so some
of my cousins and stuff
that's actually how we started venturing
that way we saw we started attending
their church
and really liked what we saw because it
just looked like there was
action you know it looked like god's
moving here right we're not sitting in
stiff pews singing hymnals you know
right so right
i was in that environment i was seeing
things that
were miraculous i was seeing like my
cousin
stretch his arm out of a cast and you
know seeing these
exciting things and around age nine
i remember my mom went inside the
grocery store and i stayed out in the
car because i just didn't want to go in
the boring grocery store
and while i was out there i was just
alone with my thoughts
and i really started realizing like the
the truth of
i am a sinner that needs a savior really
hit home and i
i even cried and i asked jesus into my
heart and i knew
that i needed a savior that was like
maybe that was um
what they call it the like the age
coming of age sort of like where you're
accountability accountability yeah i
actually i feel like that was when i
reached that spot i knew the truth
about it so i invited christ to my heart
when my mom came out i told her what
happened
had been the best day of her life to
hear that her son accepted christ
i started going to these youth groups in
this
wild church you know so we were
literally like mosh pitting to
dc talk jesus freak and stuff like this
was
and of course that was fun and exciting
but i was surrounded by all these people
who believed in god
um they were going on mission trips and
things like that so
i was in a godly environment where
people believed in god
but around age 12 i don't know i just
started
i started to i can now look back and see
how much influence the media has
because my parents would go on these
kicks where it's like well we're not
going to watch
we're not going to watch the simpsons
we're not going to watch beavers and by
head and
you know mtv and stuff like that and
they would you know try to lock out the
channels and stuff
but i was at the age where i could stay
home by myself
and so when they'd leave i would you
know be watching mtv and stuff
and that world just looked exciting i
mean rock stars you know
yeah and then you see like spring break
and everybody's in bikinis and hooking
up and getting drunk and it's like that
looked fun
and i knew that was not that was what
opposite of christianity
right you know right those aren't
christians out there yeah but they're
the ones having fun
they're they're they're not following
any sort of moral laws
they're literally just like hey let's
just yeah let's just have fun while
we're young
yeah yolo you only live once and they're
just having a good time
so i started being drawn into that i was
liking the music and then one day i saw
this guy named marilyn manson
it was a the first time he ever like
appeared on tv um
a song called sweet dreams and i was
just like instantly attracted to that
i i can look back and realize there was
these shows called like ricky lake and
stuff where they would
um these talk shows where their parents
like my my child's out of control and
they'd come out wearing like black
lipstick
and black hair and even as a young kid i
always looked at that and there's
something
attractive about it to me you know is it
just because it was like
you know causing fear in people or
something like what's that i don't know
people people would often say you're
trying to
you're seeking attention i was like no i
actually hate when people stare at me or
whatever right
i don't know i don't know you know we're
just drawn to sin you know there's
something
about it there was something really dark
and sinister with with him
especially i mean him coming out with
the whole album jesus christ
yeah superstar yeah antichrist superstar
yeah i'm forgetting how long ago this is
just to
show who he is he would on stage there'd
be like this huge
pulpit that he would stand up on and
then these banners would drop down that
looked like
hitler but they were like his logo and
he would rip out pages of the bible
and throw him out in the audience and um
and his album was called antichrist
superstar
and he was singing about stuff that even
as a christian in that
baptist type world i had never heard of
like he had a song called little horn
i didn't even know what that was and he
was saying little horn is here
and stuff so he was really pushing some
you know anti-christians got to know the
prophecies and stuff
to be able to put that into your music
you know these aren't guys that are just
like oh that sounds cool you know what i
mean i guarantee you
that guy if you sat down and had like a
great controversy bible study with him
yeah he'd probably shock you with how
much information he knows about it
yeah even if he was just studying it to
twist it because i think his whole
mission
actually his whole mission was to
destroy christianity right he said
christians are just holding us back you
know
so you get it caught up in this whole
mess of things yeah so
i'm attracted to this but i'm at a age
where i can't really
dress that way or whatever my parents
aren't going to go for that at this
point i'm
i'm pretty young when that happened at
age 12 i just started having these real
skeptical
thought-provoking questions and i'd ask
my parents you know how come
how come god says thou shalt not kill
yet he murdered the entire world with a
flood and they're just like
i don't know you know and i'd ask
pastors these types of things
and they'd be like well you know there's
some things we just won't know till we
get to heaven
what kind of answer is that you know to
me it sounds like a cop-out and i'm like
christians don't even know
why they believe what they believe so
why am i going to
you know dedicate my life to this when
they don't even know what they believe
or why they believe it
so again the media i started seeing
these movies like the craft and these
hot chicks are doing all this cool
casting spells and changing the color of
their hair and their eyes and
driving down a street and changing the
color of the light and it didn't make it
look fantasy this made it look more like
you can do this at home you can practice
this you can use a ouija board and
spell books and all this so i began
to to use the internet and search into
i'd read forums of people who were
practicing this stuff and i would
look up how do you do binding spells and
things like that and was just
really getting sucked into this world is
it because you're like wielding power
like you have power over the elements or
power over people is that kind of what
the
the real attraction to it yeah i think
it is the power
and for me i've always been a truth
seeker as long as i can remember
even back in i went to school in the
public school system and in elementary
school
i would check out books on aliens ufos
ghosts
and not like fantasy these are like
photographs of there's a ghost or
there's a ufo
right and i've just always wondered what
is out there there's something out there
i i never consider myself
an atheist atheist just like it's
science there's nothing out there
i knew there was a mystery in the world
and i wanted to know the truth about it
yet christians didn't have the answers
they were dropping the ball
right right many many christians don't
have the answers to that
and and you know it's it's unfortunate
because there are some things in the
world that i think that we should have
answers for i mean the bible's full of
of explanations and we should know
how to address some of these topics when
they come up
for prime example when you're you know
12 years old that's when you're
starting to make a decision do i want
this in my life or not you know
yeah so by age 13 i was just
full-fledged
agnostic but anti-christ i mean
i was dressed in all black wearing the
makeup
um depressed because it's like if this
life
is just one life span and then you're
dead and then
nothing you did in life matters i mean
right you could be the biggest rock star
on earth
you're gonna die and be forgotten all of
it's deleted
what is the point what's the purpose of
of earning up
you know going to school and becoming a
doctor or an inventor
or the biggest rock star on earth if
it's just gone right you could be
there'd be no difference in being
a prisoner all your life because in the
end it's the same results right
you might as well have fun while you're
here that was exactly what i ended up
doing was
just trying to think of it differently i
was like well i got one life to live i
might as well
have all the fun i can indulge in all
the mindless indulgence
pleasure that i could you know which
just drove me to terrible deeper deeper
things like that
yeah like just drunkenness experimenting
with drugs
experimentation in every avenue and just
trying to fulfill
every lustful desire imaginable
and when you when you step back and look
at the big picture
all those roads lead to destruction
that's right at the moment it seems like
fun you know
but then you step back and you're like
man how many brain cells did i kill how
how much damage did i do to my liver or
how many people
could i have killed in that drunk
driving accident or whatever right
and and so while it looks fun it's a
destructive road
right right um so i'm
living this way for a while and i've
never stopped being a truth seeker but
during that time me and my friend
decided to to
form this like two-man band it was a
like an industrial gothic band we were
both into marilyn manson and nine inch
nails and
that was that was the genre we were
going for
and i just wanted to be as shocking as
you could be so everything i said was
totally antichrist and to the point
where it even made him uncomfortable
wow like he wasn't a believer per se
super blasphemous in your in your lyrics
and things
yeah just like mocking the crucifixion
and everything you know
um but you know he wasn't even a
believer but this stuff made him
uncomfortable because he knew
oh yeah by the way i had moved to this
small
really small town in georgia and i was
just like total outcast there
everybody's like
you know redneck and proud of it to call
somebody a redneck
they were proud of that it wasn't like a
right
a bad term or anything and so
while i'm in this environment you know
that's why i made him uncomfortable
because he's like well most of the
population is christian
and these things you're saying are just
way out there but
i just wanted to be a shock rocker i
wanted to shock people and so
i was living this way for all this time
and i just reached like a rock bottom
man like
like you know that life's not fulfilling
yeah like the more the more parties you
go to the more
you know events that you you are
blaspheming god it's like you don't walk
away without
feeling good you know what i mean
exactly
but so i've been living in this small
town and just wanted to move back to
chattanooga like every day of my life i
was just like man i missed chattanooga
and i graduated from high school and my
parents were going through a divorce
it's just one more depressing thing to
add to a teenager's life but
during that divorce me and my dad
decided to move back to chattanooga we
were only living in georgia for my mom's
side of the family
and my cousin my cool cousin who i
always looked up to
drove five hours in his pickup truck to
help us move
mom and when he got there him and my mom
were discussing things and they were
talking and i found out my crew my
my cousin became a christian they were
starting to share each other's
testimonies
and i had heard my mom share testimony
this is this is always something i got
to include
my mom all her life growing up was
fear-based conversion if you do not say
this prayer you will burn
for eternity right and she saw a little
girl when she was young
burned in a fire and to her it was
terrifying she was like
i would never want that to happen to me
and i can't imagine doing that for
eternity and never ending and so every
night she would go to bed
and say lord uh save me right now
because i don't want to die and go to
hell and she'd be like
i hope that i hope that worked because
like it didn't like it didn't matter
what your moral life
was you know it's like you follow just
because you're
you're fearful of what's going to happen
at the very end and
and most of all it wasn't out of love
right it wasn't lord you've done all
this for me i want to serve you for
eternity it was like
anything but that right right right and
and god is not
he gets no pleasure out of fear-based
conversion right
god does not want heaven or the eternal
earth to be full of people who are like
well i really didn't sign up for this
but i sure didn't want the alternative
you know right
he wants people who are just like lord
i'll do anything for you you've changed
my life
you're the whole reason i'm alive you
know he's looking for true friendship
true love and that does not come out of
fear right
um so she battled this her whole
life living in fear and then
when we started hanging out with my
cousins who went to this new church
she really like started seeking like i
want a true
salvation i want to i really want to
invite christ in my life i don't want
him to change
and but she she just had this like
complication like i can't understand how
you believe something in your heart and
not your head she always
was told you have to believe it in your
heart you have to believe that you
believe that you believe you know
this assurance and she just couldn't
figure out how to do that
and one day she was at a bible study
with my uncle and he just kept reading
scripture which was awesome
scripture scripture scripture and he got
to one verse
and she said it was like god stopped her
on that verse and he just kept reading
and she said it was like he tuned out in
the background and she was like well
go back to that verse you just read
something about believe and he said it
it's this verse i wish i knew the
reference right now but he said
if you can't believe all things are
possible to him that believeth
right and all things are possible to him
that believe yeah and it was like
she said god literally gave her a vision
of a
of a dictionary unfolding and she could
tell you it was like on the left page
this column and gave her the perfect
definition of the word believe and how
to do it
and all of a sudden she was just like i
can believe i can believe and like
god just made sense of what she was
struggling with
using the word of god and from that
moment on she accepted christ
and she never doubted again and it was a
totally different it was not fear-based
conversion she
surrendered her life to god and so
throughout my teenage years i would hear
her share this testimony all the time
every chance she got she would share
this testimony and it would just make my
skin crawl
which is weird because now i look at
that and like that's the power of the
word that's the power of
testimonies that i was so full of
evil and demons and who knows what that
every time my mom would share this
amazing story that transformed her life
it would make my skin crawl and i want
to leave the room interesting
yeah so now my my cousin and my mom are
sharing their testimonies before while
we're packing up our things to
to move back to chattanooga in my
cousin's truck
and i'm just kind of overhearing a
little bit
what he's saying about how his life has
changed he's my older cousin i always
looked up to and
i always thought he was cool and now
he's a christian and
so we took we loaded up my dad's car and
my cousin's truck
well my dad drove and i got stuck in the
truck with my cousin
and i say stuck i i enjoyed being with
him but i'm in the i'm stuck just me and
him for five hours he's got me for five
hours to preach to me man nice
and so for the whole driveworks yeah for
the whole drive
and and it was like perfect timing it
was god timing i was at this
low you know my parents are getting
divorced nothing's fulfilling
i'm moving away which is good but at the
same time i'm you know i'm being
separated from
exactly all this is like fresh and it
was just like this perfect timing
and he was connecting with me on ways
that my parents couldn't
my parents are my parents they're old
you're from the past
right you don't think like i do right
and now my cousin's like
dude my whole life has changed he's like
this book has the answers to everything
he's like dude i'll just sit
in the tub and fast and just read and
it's like the whole atmosphere around me
changes
and he was like reaching me where i was
at he was like
it's kind of like that magic stuff
you're into like it's a miraculous book
you read it and things happen
i pray and i see miracles happen wow and
that he was intriguing me
interesting and how the holy spirit knew
like what would kind of like open up
your
heart to him you know in fact maybe if
he came at a different angle you'd be
like yeah whatever
yeah like you can you can live
righteously here
yeah you know i'd be like yeah but he
you know god is so personal he knows how
to
how to communicate with you on your
level and he really intrigued me and so
when i moved back to chattanooga i
really started thinking about it i was
like
i hate when people judge me for the way
i look
you know i would have friends that would
say my parents don't like me to hang out
with you
because the way i look or whatever and
then i'd meet the parents finally and
they're like oh you're nothing like i
thought you would be
and i i would always be like man these
people are judgmental you know
and so i realized i was being judgmental
why am i judging god
by all the hypocrites that represent
them and all these little
things i'm trying to do to debunk the
bible and when i've never even read it
yep which is so
often the case people look at
christianity or a poor representation of
what we're supposed to be like and they
go i don't want to be like that if that
guy's like that i don't want to be like
that
not not thinking that you know we're
engaged in a full-blown war
i mean if satan is is looking at the
situation like a military operation
he's not going to go after the people
that are already on his side
i mean sure he's deceiving them as well
but he's going to put his concentration
and his effort on
those individuals and and throw a lot of
junk
at them so that's why i think when you
look at christianity and you go wow
they're really messed up well yeah
they've got
legions of angel evil angels trying to
influence them
yeah sayings like i've already won them
over i don't need to work on them
anymore i need to get
that's right jesuits in the church or
whatever infiltration you know yeah
and so i realized i was judging god
unjustly i mean i was i hadn't read the
bible myself
i'm pointing the finger at all these
people and so i really just reached a
spot where i was like i've tried
everything else
everything else brings me hopeless
hopelessness emptiness
drugs sex the occult none of it brought
joy none of it brought
anything that i felt like i could die
for you know
and so my cousins which was my cousin's
sister
and her husband they opened up their
home to me and my dad to live with them
until
we could get on our feet and so i
started reading the bible man i just
started with genesis and i would read it
and
it it was just mind blowing to me i was
like i've never heard any of this stuff
in church i've been in church my whole
life
i've never heard stuff in genesis you
know right because there's always like
these
core stories that you hear over and over
in the new testament
yeah in the new testament for sure and
so i'm just like mind blown i'm like wow
this book really is interesting you know
and then um my so at this time if you
can tell i
had piercings and everything in my face
and was having a tough time finding a
job i thought i was going to be moving
back to the city and i could get a job
wearing all this stuff but
went that way every i started to get
interviews
and three times i had an interview in
the job
and during the interview the boss would
say oh and you know you can't wear all
this stuff in your face
wow and i literally stood up and said oh
i didn't realize you discriminated
against people with piercings and i walk
out of there
wow i mean like i needed a job i'm
living with my cousins who are waiting
on us to get on our feet and i'm walking
out of
interviews but i thought i was like
doing
you know pioneering the way for my kids
who were gonna have to struggle and all
this stuff
right and it got to the point where my
cousin
and her husband sat me down and said you
know your dad's got a job already
um it's not enough to help you guys get
on your feet yet
and you've walked out of three
interviews you know because of these
piercings
they're like maybe god's trying to tell
you these are like an idol in your life
or something and i was like
whatever i was just like i just do what
i got to do you know i realized
that i need to do what i need to do so i
took out all my piercings put on a
collared shirt and
went down this long road of all these
jobs and uh
you know finally the last the last place
on my list to go
was this place called smokey bones it
was a barbecue restaurant
and i go in there and i'm talking to
this lady who's the manager
and while i'm talking to her she notices
that i got two holes on my lip
and she goes oh you got lip rings i said
yeah you know
got to take him out get a job for the
man and and she goes oh i understand
and she flipped out a septum piercing
which is this thing she flipped it out
she had it hidden up in her nostrils
and she's like oh wow yeah she's like oh
yeah i understand
and she goes come back tomorrow i want
to introduce you to my general manager
so it was just because of that which was
weird you know it was like a little
connection because of the piercing thing
but
she liked me and told me to come back
the next day i got the job
so i'm working at this job that i hate
having to take my piercings out every
day like
they're getting infected and i'm just
like hating every minute of it but
after a couple weeks of working there um
me and her would always talk
and i said yeah i really been trying to
get a job at hot topic i said i
i xeroxed my application 10 times
and gave it to him every day this place
if you don't know it's a store in the
mall that's their slogan is all about
the music
and and when you walk by you just hear
right metal music blasting out of that
dark store like you know they i think
they sell magic stuff
and it used to be a lot darker they've
they've kind of sold out or whatever but
yeah you used to smell like leather and
right right right
they sold all the marilyn manson stuff
and i really wanted to work there
because you can
dress in normal clothes you can have
your piercings in
when i say normal clothes i mean like
you could dress gothic right right
but um when i told her that i said yeah
i really want to get a job at hot topic
and i've been trying to
do it for weeks now try to get a job
but you got to know somebody to get a
job there they know that
a bunch of weirdos are trying to apply
there so they want to make sure that
nobody comes it's a thief or whatever
right so you really have to know
somebody to get the job there
and she goes oh my my best friend's the
manager there oh wow
dude what i forgot to say was while i
was reading the bible
i started putting god to the test and
praying like for a job at hot topic
interesting i was like lord if you're
real reveal yourself to me through this
word
and give me this job at hot topic and i
was putting in the applications every
day you know i was like
calling to check up hey did you guys
check that application and
it's like almost like tr treating god a
bit like a genie yeah
you know what i mean i hear my three
wishes you give me my wishes they don't
believe in you
that's the way i felt too i felt like i
was supposed to pray the prayer and
open my eyes and it would materialize
right in front of me
but god was answering that prayer and
she said my best friend's the manager
over there and i'm going to tell her
that you're a good worker when they have
an
opening to consider you three months
later
i'm talking a few short three months
this place didn't hire that often
and within three months i was working at
hot topic
and i realized that this was god
answering my prayer because it wasn't
that god is a magical genie making
things materialize
they weren't hiring god can't i mean i'm
not saying god can't but it's not like
he's just gonna
push somebody out make somebody drop
dead and you're gonna get their position
right he was working through the the
natural
so he was guiding my path uh you're
gonna get this
job because that's the person who knows
the manager who's gonna get you the job
and you're gonna have your
uh answer you're gonna have your answer
to your prayer and
i didn't i didn't look at this like yeah
all my
effort all my applications and meeting
the right people
i was like wow god answered my prayer
and he did it in a way where i would
know it was him
interesting that's how god's so personal
he's not going to do this for everybody
you know right
he's not going to give everybody like a
vision or whatever but he will sometimes
if you need that that's what he's going
to do and he did it
he did what he did for me in a way that
made sense and i had a post-it note and
i wrote god got me the job at hot topic
thank you jesus and i stuck it on my
mirror and i saw it every day
wow and and people might think that's
weird god got you a job at a place that
sells metal music and has piercings but
it's it's these small steps of him
revealing himself to me and and changing
me over time
so i started believing god i was like
man this bible's real i'm believing in
god i'm
i'm believing in and prayer
but i'm just not ready to become a
christian yet right right
oh man a christian for real i'm in the
clubs dude i'm like working at hot topic
i'm
i'm finally living the dream you know
and and i'm having fun so you're like
thanks
god for the job and then you just kind
of go about your own world
yeah well in my mind i'm thinking you
know now that i know you're real
i'll give my life to you on my deathbed
and i'll i'll be with you in heaven for
eternity you know
it's just this twisted mindset i think a
lot of people fall for that too like
that christianity isn't really a life
change it's just i get to go to heaven
when i die right and
and then everything will change god will
change you know when the change comes
i'll be changed
right so you know now i'm
still living this party animal lifestyle
nothing's really
changed except i do believe in god and
i'm i'm praying to him and stuff
and um one night and and when you work
at hot topic
you get all these mall rack kids that
just look up to you like like a
celebrity like oh you work at hot topic
and i started this clothing line called
execute clothing
and all these kids like really loved it
i started buying it
and it and it really took off i started
um
like giving out samples to models all
over the world
california spain australia literally all
over the world and then
getting bands metal bands and wrappers
to wear my brand so there was dr acula
chelsea grin attila then if anybody
knows
soulja boys who soulja boy is his clique
so jabbar little arab
little playboy um they were wearing my
clothes and stuff
and i wasn't making any money off of
this is all just promotion this was the
beginning
stages but i did have like
a local celebrity status and me and my
friend
as a joke started like this rap group
where it was real gimmicky everything
was about
we were just like what's every rap about
uh
beer girls smoking blunts and you know
all the cars or whatever
so we just made these songs that were
about that stuff
and it was just real gimmicky and the
first night we had it
we were like invited at this show it was
actually
a fashion show entertainment
so i was there to i had runway models
wearing my execute clothing
but then me and my friend did one song
we did a set with one song and i was
wearing like this bandana over my eye
like tupac
and had my shirt off and all the tattoos
were drawn on me and stuff
and we had these hundred dollar bills
with his face my friend's face on it
and we're just like throwing out money i
had fly girls and stuff so it was like
it looked bigger than it was you know
right we would say fake it till you make
it
yeah it was right and because of that
everybody just loved this thing and
wanted more so we started doing a
monthly show at this club
and we started writing songs and and
performing shows
and it would just pack out i mean this
little club just
packed to the doors were busting open
and
we would uh represent bud ice which is a
real cheap nasty beer
but my friend actually had an interview
or like a meet up with one of the bud
ice representatives
and they said we're seeing a spike of
sales in your area oh wow
and we're going to start giving you bud
ice
for your shows so we can't technically
legally call it a sponsorship yet right
but we're going to give you free beer
for your shows that's interesting so i
mean this was like
i thought my dreams were being fulfilled
like people are starting to give us free
stuff
yeah free stuff and so we're having all
these parties and stuff
and um and like i said when you're the
celebrity status like i didn't have any
trouble
finding a party to go to or whatever
like literally when i was at work
my phone would be blowing up and there'd
be like three or four people asking me
what are you doing tonight there's this
part of that party so i was like oh i
get to choose where i'm gonna go tonight
you know
but one particular night in april of
uh nobody was hitting me up and i was
hitting everybody where's the party at
oh i'm actually hanging out with a girl
tonight or oh i'm out of town
nobody was there to hang out with and it
was kind of like a relief it was like
well
sometimes i felt overwhelmed with
friends so i i just went home
and i just started watching the simpsons
i'm just relaxing
and all of a sudden i felt like god was
saying
why don't you pray and i was like that's
weird
but i believe in god and i believe in
prayer and it just felt like this nudge
you know so
i said all right and i hit mute i did
what i felt led to do i
meeted the tv and i just started praying
i was trying to think of things to pray
about lord help this friend i know
they're in trouble and help this person
and
and while i was praying i felt
like i heard god say this is your moment
and i opened my eyes i was like wait a
minute because i knew it was about
becoming a christian and i still wasn't
ready for that yet
right i thought and open my eyes i'm
like oh no
that must have been some random thought
that wasn't god you know
but then when i thought that it was like
a smack of reality it was like
you're seeking for truth you're looking
for god god has
shown himself to you and you are
rejecting him he's saying this is your
moment
and you're saying no and i was like
i can believe in the bible i can believe
in god i can believe he's answering my
prayers
why can't i believe he's saving my life
right now and it was that same word
belief
the same word for my mom right when i
had that thought
why can't i believe these things god
showed me things like
he brought to my memory of my mom
telling her testimony believing all
things are possible to him to believeth
he showed me this little mirror magnet
that i bought my mom for mother's day
that said that verse on there i bought
it for her
because that was her verse and then god
is so cool and personal he even used
this
i used to play this video game called
paw rapper the rapper and it's this
little rapping dog
and you make them say the words but when
you beat this certain level he spins
around and he says
i just got to believe and i always
thought it was like comical you know
and god like threw that in my mind and
i'm just like wow
and it was just like god was saying like
he's so personal
i'm cool i'm the reason you think things
are cool or funny i'm the one that
created you
and created all these emotions that you
feel and i just like
felt god all over and i just surrendered
right then and said god i believe that
you're saving my life right now
come into my life change me i want to
start living for you i'm not afraid
to become a christian anymore and so
that day i invited god into my life
but i'm still a baby christian man i was
still like it's all a growth you know it
wasn't an overnight change for me so
i did accept christ and i probably
wasn't doing
the best at bible study and everything
so
i was still living this lifestyle
that was 2005 2011
is when god really opened my eyes about
the signs of the times i didn't think we
were really living in the last days i
was just
it just didn't feel like it but then god
kind of like
made the veil fall and i was just like
wow new world order and all this stuff
and it made revelation make sense to me
it made me
believe the bible even more because i'm
like wow the bible predicted all this
stuff you see those things unfolding in
our world
today yeah and so i was starting to tell
christians about that like wow you guys
are right you know we are in the last
days look at this and this and this and
they're like
oh that's conspiracy theory i'm like
yeah conspiracy
you're saying we're in the last days and
you're not seeing it happen how how are
you not getting this
um so then i was like man these people
but i i started doing bible studies with
my
ex-girlfriend's dad who was a baptist
and uh he wanted to do bible studies
with me every wednesday so he'd come to
my house and
i mean at this point i was i was
drinking a beer during bible study and
stuff i mean i just
i god is patient yes and and i
sometimes i look back like was i really
a christian you know with
but it says in acts that god winks at
your sins committed in ignorance
and i i think that i probably was
because i was thinking well
jesus turned water into wine i mean why
can't i drink a beer he said every green
herb bearing seed i'm gonna smoke up
this green herb you know
so i was like self-deceived and i and i
um knew that solomon had all these wives
and stuff and
so i felt like i was living this type of
lifestyle i'm a rapper i got these girls
and
alcohol and all this but i'm doing bible
studies
which is another thing ivor myers is
doing we're smoking are we having bible
study
yeah so um he starts trying to show me
the pre-tribulation rapture
and i'm like where is it at i don't i
don't see what you're saying he said
well
some people believe in pre-trib mid-trib
and post-true but we believe pre-trib
and that's
and he said because it says you're
changing the moment of twinkling and i
and i'm like
yeah i see that but i also see
christians being beheaded for not taking
the mark so
i don't get this in this timeline you're
saying and he would always be like well
we can agree to disagree
let's just keep studying or whatever
which was cool i'm glad that he did that
with me
but i was a valet at a hospital and i
started finding
these little tracks called signs of the
times and i'd read it and it'd be like
people have these near-death experiences
of hell but this is what the bible says
and i'm like
wow the bible says that a week or two
later somebody knocks on my door
i literally answered the door with a
beer in my hand i'm still drinking all
the time
wow and and i'm talking to him through
the doorway
and he's just hey uh just in the area
and you know and i thought it was cool i
love talking
to christians i'm a christian now and
and i start
i ask them hey man you ever heard a new
world order
because everybody else was telling me
i'm conspiracy theory a theorist um
he pulls out this flyer out of his back
pocket and unfolds it and he said you
should come to this event
the first night said new world order
nice dude
there's a church that actually talks
about this kind of stuff talk about god
like knows where you're at and like puts
people in your path and connecting the
dots man
because i was like wow so i went to this
event
and uh i didn't get to make every night
so i kind of missed some of the
things but i knew that they knew some
truth man and so this guy kept coming
back and was studying with me
and he knew that if i could see it in
the bible i'm going to believe it he
didn't have to
tiptoe around and let's go through all
these little beliefs he was just like
i'll give you this presentation that
talked about the state of the dead and
the rapture
everything all in one presentation i was
like wow it's all scripture you know
so i was i was in uh pretty quick and
and this guy who was studying with me
though that came to my door
he he realized that i was kind of a
conspiracy theorist and he was like i
think you'd like these guys
he handed me two dvds at a little light
studio it's awesome
bootleg and uh
and i watched him i couldn't believe
what i was seeing i was just like dude
these guys are seeing all the same kind
of stuff i'm starting to see you know
and i was starting to see like the
occult like blatant occult symbols and
stuff like that and a lot of stuff but
you guys were like look at the storyline
look at the person's name and i was just
mind blown
and i was like man i wish i could work
for that ministry you know they're doing
something that i can identify with
and um so i told my friend at work and i
said dude have you ever heard of little
light studios he's like
i know those guys man i got their number
that's awesome i'm like well that's cool
we said they're in california i was like
yeah yeah i wish i could work there
that's crazy they live in california
he said why don't you call him i was
like him and
do what he said i don't know just talk
to him they're cool so i
you remember oh yeah and i remember
getting the phone call i even remember
where i was sitting and you you had
called me
and you were you were asking about
moving to
california and going to hollywood and
doing some things and you kind of told
me a little bit about your
your experience with the whole rap game
and all this kind of stuff you know
and i was like i don't know man i don't
know if that's a good idea
yeah yeah i mean um so i called you and
kind of shared my testimony stuff not
knowing
you didn't know who i was for sure and
uh
but that was still kind of my my plan i
mean my house
all my furniture was in storage already
i had a box of money
saved to go like a couple thousand
dollars that i was saving up tips
and my friend had already moved out
there he was living with his girlfriend
this is the guy that you were a rapper
with right yeah yeah he wasn't on the
same page as i was but like i said i was
going to try to get a reputation and
then start spreading this truth
and just a little bit before that
me and my friend had already shot a
video in california
so we were at a mansion dude a mansion
with a swimming pool
girls in bikinis beer everywhere and and
the guy who was shooting the
the music video had done work on the
green mile he was
uh he shot reality shows for mtv and we
had a whole
cast and crew set like they were doing
people's hair and
wardrobe and everything now where'd you
get the funding for all this or
people just do it for free it was just
connects man
the girl that uh we knew in california
put out an ad on craigslist
she was like she didn't say who the
artist was
it was like artists under clothes so
people were like oh it might be scary
so people just started showing up you
know they're all in california because
they want to do this as a career so
they're trying to get their foot in the
door right
and so all these people showed up yeah
so we did pay
um the cameraman said he would only work
for free
if we paid his light men he said i only
work with these certain light guys and
they'll do it for 100 bucks
so we paid them and then one of the
models was like
i wasn't really sure it was free i need
to get home so i think we bought her an
uber or something
so really the whole thing just like i
said
i really believed that god was was like
making my dreams come true i felt like
this is king solomon you know this
he's answering all my dreams um and it
was it was weird it was real
supernatural kind of because i would
just always bump into the right people
at the right time and
have these celebrities wearing my
clothes and stuff and
when i came back from having that music
video shot
i changed my flight date to a day later
i was like i need to stay here one more
day so i changed my date
and then in the lax airport at the same
terminal as me
as this guy wearing head to toe
sodmg which is soldier boy's record
label
and i went over there i was like do you
know are you with uh sod money gang he
go he smiled he goes
i'm the ceo wow i'm like dude no way
like
i'm from chattanooga i came out here
just shooting a music video i'm showing
them behind the scenes and he's like
whoa y'all doing a big i was like
dude this is my clothing line pulling
shirts out of my bag and then i'm
showing on my phone
pictures of his guys wearing my clothing
line he's just like
whoa what and so i'm starting to give
him clothes so he can give the soulja
boy and stuff
and uh this guy did a promo video with
me in the airport like i
got some random stranger hold the camera
and we're like yeah we out here in
california
and like this guy was even like can you
watch my louis vuitton bags while i go
to the store and stuff like
wow it was just like dude this is crazy
when i talked to him he said you know
what i actually changed my flight to a
day earlier
so i was like man this is so
supernatural like i changed my date to a
day later he changed his date to a day
earlier and we
and we meet up and i just really felt
like god was fulfilling my dreams
and then it was like god said
you see how close you are to this dream
you see the bud-eyes sponsorships you
see the
celebrities wearing your clothing line
you got all the connections if you
continue this it will happen
right i mean you're you're planning on
moving to california you got all these
people waiting on you
or you can lay it all down and live for
me and for what i have for you
wow my story is not well i tried and
everything came crumbling down
so i was like god all right it was i was
at the peak
and just like jesus came to the
fisherman they had the biggest catch of
the day he said drop your nets and
follow me
he's like they couldn't even bring the
nets in you know they were breaking and
he was like drop it all
finally they've made it and then it's
like abandon it
and that's where it was for me and i i
feel like god kind of allowed you know
was
allowing me to do that for a while
because
he knew that if i would have just jumped
right into christianity full-fledged
always on the back of my mind what would
happen if i would have done it my way
right right right right
um which i have seen happen i've seen
with some of my other friends that just
kind of like overnight
i'm vegan i don't i'm sober and all this
stuff and they fall back right you've
seen it to you right
so so yeah you know you're bringing up a
good point i mean the way that god often
works
is he he he sees the end result
yeah so he's like not concerned
necessarily about the just
immediate he knows what is going to
bring you to this point over here
and i think that that powerful choice
where
that's kind of what our immo is with our
ministry it's like we show people what
what goes on in the movies right but we
actually don't tell them what to do yeah
you know what i mean it's like then then
it's this point of like we're going to
show you the information but then it's
up to you because
you making that decision i want to
unplug yeah i don't want to watch this
stuff anymore
is more powerful than me going you need
to do this
and then they they um make a knee-jerk
reaction or something
yeah and i you know you it's probably
happened before like at ivor myers thing
like get rid of all your movies
the altar call but then it's like when
does that collection just fill back up
again
right and to be honest that happened
with me right i saw his thing and i was
like we're throwing it all out in the
collection built back up you know
but god was patient he was
allowing me to make the the decision so
i reached this point
and it was in uh it was around 2012
that um i decided yeah i called my
friend who was already in california
waiting on me to move there
and i knew he was not going to take the
this night easily you know i knew he
wasn't going to take it good
because he needs you yeah like we're a
two-man band he really felt like
together we were the only way he could
do it and he's already out there and
he's already been calling me like when
you come in i'm like i'm working on it
now i'm gonna tell them i'm not coming
wow i said
i said a short prayer before i answered
before i called i was like lord
just make this go well you know don't i
don't want him to be
angry or anything i called him i told
him i was like dude i just i don't feel
like i can do
this you know i don't feel like this is
the right thing and i
you know my my plans are kind of
changing he said well you know you know
maybe we can try next year or something
like
it was just totally out of character the
way he took it so lightly
and um i'm telling you from that point
on when i made that decision
i got more serious about wanting to
study
this new bible truth that i was seeing
about prophecy and everything
and um we opened up our home to the
church to have bible study in every
thursday we'd have like
sometimes 10 to 20 people at our house
every thursday
every wednesday there'd be a woman
coming to study with my wife and a guy
coming to study with me at like
different times
and um i was really starting to feel
convicted about my lifestyle
like me and my wife were just like we
need to get married you know we were
living together and not married and
and together we just we need to get
married so we got married
and um she
was actually led to the lord through all
this because when i met her she wasn't a
believer
and her mom had become a believer
through
rehab so to her it was just seemed like
oh my mom just found guys
she's dealing with yeah another crutch
or whatever but she saw something and
me and my dad my cousin when we hung out
that she
wanted and she realized that um
that she was missing something and she
wanted she said i feel like there's a
hole in me that needs to be filled and
he's the only one that can feel it
and that was awesome so
during all these studies i'm just
feeling convicted about my lifestyle
and you know i'm still drinking and
smoking every day but now i'm like
i don't need to be doing this stuff my
house was the type of household
that somebody'd show up with a 12-pack
and
they start calling their friends the
next thing you know there's like 20
people in the house just like a party
just happens
it's a tuesday afternoon yeah exactly
and so
i'm feeling like well i'm gonna start
cutting back you know
uh i'm not gonna i'm not gonna smoke or
drink today the day i said that dude
satan sent out his minions man because
same friend free
at that point yeah some friend i hadn't
seen in months would knock on my door
hey bro haven't seen you forever i got
some beer some weed i'm like well i'm
not paying for it at least
start making excuses and i realize what
i'm saying i'm
i'll cut back i'm really holding on
right it was not a surrender
right right right and and so finally new
year's 2013
i i made a new year's resolution with
god i said
god i keep trying on my own strength i
am weak you are strong i fail
every time i'm giving you permission to
take this from me god is not a thief
he's not going to come in and steal
things that you're cherishing right
i was holding on to it but when i
surrendered it to him and gave him
permission to take it
he's like i will take it and um so i
told him that night i said i can't do it
but i want to be free from this i don't
ever want to do it again you have to
give me the strength
and that was a bold prayer because i
could have fell again and that maybe it
would have
shattered my faith or something but i
woke up the next day without a single
withdrawal man this was supernatural
because every day
people say weed is not addictive it is
every day i didn't have weed
i was irritable all day and i was
looking for it the whole day interesting
every time every day around time to get
off work
i'd start feeling nauseous and it would
go away magically when i drink my beer
so
i knew that these were withdrawal
symptoms that were gone overnight
and so that was the hardest part and i
realized that god did it
and i was starting to hear you know the
people i was studying with was talking
about jewelry and things and i
had already got rid of most of my
piercings but i did have these huge
bottle cap things in my ears and um
i didn't i wasn't convinced i was like
well you know it's not like i'm putting
gold in my ears this is just rubber and
it's not a big deal and um the night
that i told god that i was surrendering
everything to him
i woke up i had fallen asleep on the
couch and i woke up and both these plugs
were out of my ears and i was
frantically searching for them on the
couch and i
was when i found them i was looking at
them i was like they might not be
gold but i was searching for them like
they were gold interesting i'm going to
take this as a sign
and i'm just not going to put them back
in so that was like a paradigm shift in
my life new year's 2013 man was like
wow so man god is so good that he got to
that point
point and uh even to the point where i
got here man
so yeah so how did you get here how did
you get inside of little light studios
yeah that prayer was just too big to
even ask you know i tell people all the
time we don't pray big enough for god he
wants to answer the big prayers
and i didn't pray lord because i work
for little light studios because i'm
looking at the stuff
i'm like they got graphic designers
video editor their stuff looks good
they're in california people know it's
generally three of us yeah
yeah it took ten years yeah it took two
years to make that documentary
but you guys were in california i was in
chattanooga and at this point i wasn't
going to move to california now
and um so one day i got invited to be on
a commercial because i had tattoos oddly
enough
they were looking for somebody that
looked like they were a party animal
that they were going to give a
testimony track to or whatever and so i
showed up at this
shoot and i get in the car with you and
keith
and uh because it was raining and we're
waiting on some of the other people to
show up
and as we're talking somehow it got
mentioned that you guys were at little
light studios i was like whoa you guys
came all the way here from
california to shoot this commercial
you're like actually we moved here like
a year ago
i'm like what and so i'm just you know
telling you how much i like your stuff
and
how i have a burden for the youth and i
really admire what you're doing and wish
i could do the same thing
and um so i because we had kind of
talked a little bit
you told me about that you were doing
these video bible studies
these little five-minute bible studies
and invited me to come and and
shoot one on the mark of the beast issue
and while i was there i was just kind of
jokingly saying don't you guys want to
start printing t-shirts because kind of
my side hobby was screen printing
t-shirts
and you were like will your machine fit
right here in your basement
and i'm like uh yeah and you said i'm
serious
so i started like working um
another thing was i went to the salt
program and when i came
out of that my job only allowed me to
work
uh three days a week because they had to
go to part time
so two days a week i was coming to
little light and printing t-shirts
and then just over time it you know our
relationship grew
and and i i worked on a video it's like
oh you can video edit and then
you know the crew was able to expand and
so
yeah it literally became full-time it's
been really neat because
um my friendship with you is is
blossomed
and i'm encouraged um you know to hear
your story but
to have that perspective to jump on
board and then to see your creativity
and i mean you you can do graphic design
you can edit you can do all these things
that it just it just has been really
neat to see our little team
expand and grow but i i love it i mean
you know looking at pictures of you
coming from
that to now having an opportunity to
come in
and really win souls um you know through
our youtube channel or whatever
sharing your your testimony but also
connecting with people that want your
heart over
you know like understanding the mark of
the beast and these these these topics
that talk about what the end of the
world is going gonna be like
and um you know i don't think that we i
don't think we talk about these things
enough
you know there's not enough ministries
that do this so uh i agree i think
sometimes we get stuck in our little
bubble
we don't really evangelize enough and
there's a world out there with questions
especially now that things are getting
kind of crazy with this virus thing and
everything and people are starting to
what what did your bible say again
that's right but god changes lives
he changes the desires of your heart i
used to print t-shirts
for metal bands and i used to make music
videos
and now god has taken those same talents
and allowing me to use them
at this ministry where we make cool
christian t-shirts and we make
videos that share the truth so he gave
me those gifts
for a reason i was using them in the
wrong way and he changed the desires of
my heart and opened up the doors
so that i could use them and god's just
so awesome how he does that that's right
i believe that god can literally change
anybody i mean
i i too have the similar story of if you
would have seen me in my hollywood days
and told me that someday i would be a
part of a ministry and
share christ with the world i would have
laughed at you and said you're insane
um but you know here i am today and uh
here you are today
uh literally a changed man so you know
there's
there's there's power in the bible
power in pleading with god praying with
god
and if you ask those simple prayers i
mean look at that god meets you where
you're at
as you can kind of just see from mikey's
testimony
god doesn't knee-jerk you and all of a
sudden be like okay fine you need to
wear all white from here on out and do
this and that and
he he takes those little steps to bring
you closer to him
and if you allow him into your heart he
will
change you from the inside out so um
thanks mikey for sharing that with us
you know it's always
encouraging to me to see the path
of how god leads a soul to his
his kingdom and for his purposes and i
can only imagine like
one of the enjoyments that we're going
to get when we get to heaven is
literally walking around and being like
dude nebuchadnezzar what was it like
dude
you know what i mean like how did what
was the point that you actually said all
right i give my heart to god and so
um you know testimonies are powerful and
i just want you guys to know
that there is nobody too far gone listen
if you have a son
a daughter a family member a cousin a
friend
you name it that you know is straight up
giving their life to satan like what you
were doing
a part of the occult blaspheming god
they're not too far gone in fact god can
win
that soul and take them and literally
turn them around and use them for
his purposes yeah use those people to
witness to people who are in that
because
we're all different parts of the body
you're not going to be able to win
somebody in the occult if you don't know
anything about it you know or whatever
so
um this is true my my idol
was filmmaking and and and movies and
things that was my idol
and so for me to kind of come and share
what god has taught me through that
it gives me this um this ability to sort
of enter into god's work but um
but i'm using something that tripped me
up down the road
and you know you can do the same as well
like uh you know things that have gotten
you
caught up in in whatever um god can flip
that around and you're going to be a
powerful voice to reach
other people that are struggling with
those same addictions or problems and
things like that so
you know if you guys uh anyone watching
has ever felt like how could god
possibly use
me i mean i've just done the worst
things in the world look at this
prime example you can have a ministry
that wins
thousands of souls um for the kingdom of
god
you just have to open your heart and let
god change you from the inside out and
that's right we hope you guys were
blessed
thanks for tuning in and uh you know
don't forget to like subscribe
to our channel we've got tons of content
if you're new to this channel
um we have a passion for sharing the
gospel
especially through um things like pop
culture and
and topics that the youth deal with so
thank you guys for watching and we'll
catch you around on the next one
[Music]
foreign